il nous reste quelques minutes pour
parler du coronavirus alors non pas pour
faire le point de ce sujet qui est âgée
toute la planète mais je voudrais vous
faire réagir à une prise de position
assez original et j'ai trouvé
passionnant c'est celle de didier raoul
vous le connaissez pas forcément c'est
un professeur de microbiologie à
spécialiste dans son domaine il est le
directeur de l'institut hospitalo
universitaires méditerranée à marseille
et voilà ce qu'il répond quand on
l'interrogé sur la dangerosité du corona
virus est ce qu'il est plus
transmissible que les autres la réponse
pour l'instant
pas d'évidence qu'ils soient plus
transmissible que les autres est-ce
qu'il est plus mortel que les lots de la
réponse est pour l'instant il est le
même niveau de mortalité peut-être un
peu plus faible que les autres
et est ce que il a plus de chance de
muter que les autres non il va muter
comme tous les coronavirus comme tel
virus à arn mute donc tout ça moi du
point de vue de la virologie ça me
paraît relativement banal et surtout
c'est à mettre en perspective si vous
voulez avec la mortalité générale des
infections respiratoires qui
actuellement est de 2 5 millions de
personnes par an nous dans la semaine on
a eu deux patients qui sont morts de la
grippe est un patient qui est mort
devait respiratoire syncytial dans la
semaine à marseille
alors comme vous l'avez vu sur la vidéo
c'est une interview qui datent de mardi
dernier donc c'est vrai que la faire
évoluer mais c'est une bonne question
est ce que est ce qu'on en fait pas trop
ivan rioufol dans cette espèce de
d'affolement planétaire c'est difficile
là où il nous répondre je n'ai pas
d'éléments simplement il ya une
suspicion sur la source de l'information
quand elle vient de la chine communiste
donc il tint régime quand même très
totalitaire qui verrouille tout est donc
c'est pas tout à fait comme tchernobyl
basket tchernobyl on pouvait les l'épée
des pays alentour pouvez quand même
mesurer ce qui se passait exactement est
d'ailleurs tchernobyl a accéléré la
glace noste même l'effondrement du mur
avec gorbatchev
ici on est quand même dans un pays qui
au lieu de s'ouvrir se referme encore
davantage et il est en train même de de
rejouer le grand bond en avant en lui
disant regardez on construit des
hôpitaux en jour et c'est donc à une
propagande qui est en train de suivre ce
que ce régime là en plus et donc qui
fait quoi qui fait quoi qui peut
susciter
des interrogations des doutes sur les 1
sur les informations qui sont distillées
manière très précise
j'entendais le l'ambassadeur de chine à
paris et ce matin qui donnaient des
chiffres à l'unité près dé ceux qui
étaient morts de ceux qui étaient
atteints etc
on a quand on l'entend se demande si on
se moque pas un peu de nous surtout dans
un pays qui a un milliard quatre cent
rendent hommage et ce qui effectivement
pas facile
la recension bertrand perrier c'est vrai
qu'on n'est pas médecin les uns et les
autres mais votre intuition c'est quoi
c'est que c'est normal ce degré de
mobilisation ou que c'est un peu
beaucoup non c'est énorme et c'est
légitime à la fois parce que le
gouvernement est totalement tétanisée
par les suites des scandales sanitaires
précédent qui ont été horriblement mal
géré parce qu'on avait l'impression
qu'on nous cachait des choses à il ya eu
la grippe h1n1 il ya eu même la canicule
va tous les scandales sanitaires ont été
très mal géré faute de communication et
de transparence c'est d'ailleurs assez
frappant de voir que là on a une sur
information on est informé heure après
heure du état de santé de personnes
m'ont très bien et d'ailleurs on est
plus souvent informés par les médecins
que par les politiques
ce qui prouve bien que la parole des
médecins et mieux cru que celle des
politiques puisque les politiques envoie
les médecins pour communiquer et donc
parce que eux au moins ils savent de
quoi ils parlent
et donc c'est eux qui communique sur la
question du coronavirus après personnes
les médecins mais c'est vrai que dans
une communication de crise il ya un
certain nombre de règles d'or d'abord
communiquer rapidement dire ce que l'on
sait dire aussi ce que l'on ne sait pas
et dire ce que l'on fait et donc pas de
ce point de vue là en effet le
gouvernement communique beaucoup parce
qu'il est je pense
il ya une trouille absolue de l'accident
de l'af et news parce que ça aussi ça va
commencer à circuler sur les réseaux et
donc c'est une communication de
l'abondance qui est la communication de
la peur vous êtes 62 % à considérer
qu'on en fait trop avec les guillemets
qui ce qui s'impose sur le coronavirus à
ce commentaire de manseau sur twitter la
groupe tu l'agro la grippe
oulala la grippe tue en france c'est
mieux comme ça entre environ dix mille
personnes par an là on n'est même pas à
10 depuis le début de la contamination
chaque mort est horrible mais il faut
relativiser
alors c'est vrai et en même temps chers
manceau diaz l'argument de certains qui
disent ne comparons pas le coronavirus
avec la grippe parce que notamment le
risque de contagion n'est pas du tout le
même par exemple dans les équipes
hospitalières
quand vous quant à l'hôpital on soigne
un patient atteint de la grippe on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir ces combinaison de
cosmonaute parce que c'est beaucoup
moins c'est beaucoup moins le risque
encore une fois de contamination et - le
corps d'un virus a déjà tué la bourse de
shanghai nous dit citoyen sur figaro
live et puis romain qui le dit en tout
cas ce virus a permis aux chinois de
construire deux hôpitaux en dix jours
nous avec nos 35 heures et nos grèves
trois petits points
sans doute qu'on est moins performant
laurence taillade votre pas dans un
régime de nature non plus non je sers
effectivement saada contre pas facile
mobilisation justifiée que principe de
précaution poussé que je vais vous dire
je pense que dans un cas de santé
publique le principe de précaution doit
prévaloir donc c'est important qu'on ait
pris des mesures maintenant il faut
regarder les mesures qui ont été prises
les principes veut le fait de mettre les
personnes en quarantaine tout ça très
bien par contre le fait de rapatrier des
français c'est ça a provoqué une petite
crise diplomatique quand même avec la
chine il faut le savoir parce que on a
remis en doute la capacité de la chine à
mettre en quarantaine de repas une
ressortissants français pour nous les
expédier en suit donc la chine a été un
peu un peu frustré de cette façon de la
traiter de considérer que finalement son
système de santé n'était pas perso ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose effectivement je vais revenir sur
la grippe la grippe tue effectivement en
moyenne dix mille personnes par an en
france uniquement en france
et finalement regarde ça comme une
fatalité la vaccination n'est pas
quelque chose de fréquent de courant ont
de courant on incite les personnes âgées
les personnes faibles à se vacciner mais
on n'est pas dans une méthode beaucoup
plus incitative qui pourrait y avoir
dans d'autres dans d'autres pays donc
notre problématique je pense aller
davantage là sur la pédagogie
parce que il y a depuis de nombreuses
années une défiance non seulement
vis-à-vis du politique
monsieur perrier l'a bien rappelé mais
il ya aussi une autre défiance vis-à-vis
du médecin il faut rappeler qu'il ya un
certain nombre de médecins qui sont
poursuivis pour des dérives sectaires
parce qu'ils disent qu'il faut pas se
vacciner qu' il y a qu on a vu en lui
non pas sur le corps une agression n'a
pas de vaccin mais en l'occurrence quand
des médecins avons dire qu'il ne faut
pas vacciner des enfants c'est criminel
il faut le rappeler donc il est
important de rappeler que dans notre
pays on a des choses qui peuvent sauver
des gens ça s'appelle les vaccins que
donc il faut refaire la pédagogie sur le
pass le vaccin il faut refaire leur
pédagogie sur des règles de base
d'hygiène apprendre à se laver les mains
parce que malheureusement il ya des
gamins qui sauvent pas qu'on se lave les
mains avant de passer à table qui savent
pas qu'on se lave les mains avant de
sortir des toilettes et rien que ça ça a
permis de faire baisser la mortalité
dans notre pays au début du 20e siècle
donc il serait peut-être temps aussi de
revenir à des principes de base dans
notre pays je vous propose de couvrir
cette émission sur ses conseils pleins
de bon sens merci beaucoup à tous les
3es à richard berry qui a dû nous
quitter quelques instants avant la fin
de cette émission
bonsoir à tous merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous demain pour un
nouveau numéro de point de vue